you
welcome to this press conference where
we will present this year's Nobel Prize
in Physics this year's prize is about
something very small that makes all the
difference the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences has decided to award the 2013
Nobel Prize in Physics to Professor
France or on glare at university level
do Brasil Bezique and professor Peter
Higgs at University of Edinburgh United
Kingdom in the Academy citation runs for
the theoretical discovery of a mechanism
that contributes to our understanding of
the origin of mass of sub atomic
particles and which recently was
confirmed through the discovery of the
predicted fundamental particle by the
Atlas and simius experiments at CERN at
CERN's Large Hadron Collider